let's turn our attention back to
washington where president biden's
gearing up for another
restful weekend and for joe the weekend
can't come
soon enough yesterday at the white house
he was acting
a little odd watch employers can't find
workers
i said yeah pay them more
this is an employee's
employee's bargaining chip now
what's happening i got them
1.9 trillion dollars relief so far
they're going to be getting checks in
the mail that are consequential
this week for child care the bill
on the environment why would i not be
for it
after president biden was done
aggressively whispering into that
microphone
he started to walk away until vp harris
reminded her boss
that he wasn't done speaking watch this
i've got to get a helicopter
will you travel to florida sir can we
ask you about florida what you've
learned
yes i apologize yes thank you my friend
we're working on it and i made it clear
i say to the people of florida
whatever help you want the federal
government provide
we're waiting just ask us we'll be there
wow tonight while joe biden struggles
his radical base is gaining traction
according to a scary new axios poll
socialism is increasing in popularity
and capitalism is declining joining us
now with reaction is fox news
contributor charlie hurt
and fox news contributor jason chaffetz
jason the whispering i mean this guy's
going viral twice
that's it just for tripping and now
whispering doesn't really make an impact
but when he does
what do you think here
it's very creepy i can't believe it it's
just
weird i mean come on uncle joe you just
don't do that stuff
you're talking about the economy and
trillions of dollars
and you're whispering like you're
talking to some i
i don't know they got did they get the
meds all balanced out jesse i
i can't explain this charlie what is the
whispering to you what is you
you're a biden whisperer tell us what
you think is going on here is he trying
to like
lower his cadence and and bring
everybody into attention
i don't know what he's trying to do and
i don't know and if the idea
is to try to get attention for himself
he's obviously getting attention for
himself
but not in a good way it's really creepy
it's really weird
uh and then the other thing is that the
the thing that he had forgot to mention
i don't know was a building collapse in
florida
and then he comes back to the microphone
and starts joking around about it
i'm sorry this is not funny that's not
funny
it's a and it's beyond creepy because uh
it really does raise serious questions
about who the heck is in charge over
there at the white house right now
well i mean you can even see the puppet
strings the media won't even talk to you
about it it's the creepy thing comes up
because when you hear the whisper
you think of the hair nuzzling remember
the massaging
the sniffing of the hair and that's what
he was known for
and now he's bringing it back i have a
theory jason you tell me if i'm accurate
here
the guy's not a strong communicator we
know that and he's got
three tells number one when he says come
on man
he's basically given up he can't
persuade so he just says come on man
second tell the temper that's when he
wags his finger that's when he loses his
cool
the third tell is the whisper that's
when he wants to say hey guys
i got everything under control and
yesterday he thought he did have
everything under control
because he thought he cut a deal on
infrastructure turns out he really
didn't cut that deal
well that's a problem he goes out and
goes in front of the media then they
went back and they whispered in his ear
and they said
uh mr president you can't do that deal
uh
you're not allowed to do that it's like
when he goes to the microphone jesse
and he's going to talk to the media the
few times he does it and he says i'm
going to get in trouble if i don't call
on the right person
i mean you bet you're right come on man
he just he doesn't know what to say well
maybe he's getting in trouble by kamala
you never know who really is running the
show there so
i hate even to talk about this poll
because it makes me depressed
charlie this axios poll what's happening
why is this country now have positive
feelings about socialism
you explain this to me have has the
right done a poor job
explaining the benefits of capitalism
and just kind of
let the left come fill that void
well i think without a doubt um and
donald trump exposed all of this
where we saw this this huge cleave
between
regular republican voters and the
republican party which is far more
beholden to corporate interests
than they are to to to their voters and
i think that that's
more what that poll reflects than uh
necessarily an embrace of socialism
but without a doubt there's an alarm and
nobody has done more
coverage of this than you jesse in terms
of going on to college campuses
and talking to young people and finding
out the stupid things that they believe
and that they've been taught
and it seems really sort of bad timing i
mean if you're you know at a moment when
the government has never been
richer more powerful and more
incompetent
you have more young people going towards
a
form of government that believes the
government should be
in charge of every aspect of our lives
and it's so
it's sort of weird but you have to
remember we're we're in the late stages
of this
of this strategy by democrats which is
to attack education and destroy
education
so kids have no history whatsoever the
second part is to attack
work and destroy work because work does
not benefit you
under socialism and the third thing is
to turn everybody against one another
uh preferably along racial lines
apparently
if the if the democrats get their way
and and
those three things together and we're at
the late stages of this strategy
this is what you wind up with and it's
truly terrifying
now i'm glad you mentioned me hitting
the streets because i did that on waters
world you'll see it on saturday at 8 and
i asked about the crime wave
and i asked new yorkers about it and a
couple of them blamed capitalism you got
to see this thing jason chaffetz i'll
give you the last word
no this is also what happens jesse when
more than half of the americans don't
pay taxes
yeah and they just think that
everything's for free root beer and all
the drinking fountains
and root beer in the drinking fountains
do they have that out in utah is that
what you're talking about
that's a utah thing i think i knew it
and you can find
that and you can find jason buy all
those drinking fountains
all right gentlemen thank you guys we
appreciate it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else